One of my favorite aspects of the Rubin
report is the feedback that we're
getting from viewers literally all over
the world.
Just last week I have viewers from
countries like Egypt,
Denmark,
Mexico,
Spain in Australia.
Reach out to me just to name a few.
I'm truly humbled at so many of you.
Take the time to share your feelings
with me and although I don't have time
to respond to everyone,
I do try to at least read the messages
that you're sending.
To me.
The most amazing part of this is that
the conversations we're having on the
show are transcending race,
religion,
sexuality and nationality.
The fight for free speech,
the importance of not giving into the
authoritarians and the awakening against
the regressives are all ideas that bring
us together.
The power of ideas is universal.
When we discuss free speech,
free thought and free expression,
it's vital that we mean it equally for
everyone,
not just in an identity,
politics based pecking order.
This device,
this thing that we all have in our
pocket is bringing us closer together in
ways that were literally unimaginable
only a generation ago.
Right?
This very second one of you is watching
this direct message while on the subway
in New York City.
One of you is listening to the podcast
while at the gym in London,
and one of you is streaming this while
on your couch in Moscow.
Not only are you all tuning in on a
variety of platforms,
but you're furthering the discussion of
these ideas on facebook and twitter or
just by talking with your friends and
family.
That expansion of our conversations
makes me want to do better work even if
talking about difficult topics comes at
both a personal and professional cost.
As the world has gotten smaller,
it has never been more important to hear
voices that challenge our thinking and
give unique perspective based on their
own personal story.
My guest this week is enough ship
Chanko.
INA is the leader of the women's
Movement Feminine International,
a columnist for the international
business times and a free speech
activist.
She was born in Ukraine in the same year
that the USSR fell,
has been kidnapped by the Bellaruse Kgb,
and in 2013 was granted political asylum
in France.
She has lived a truly controversial life
and paid the price for being outspoken
more than once.
This is not someone who only talks about
the news.
This is someone who actually lives it.
There are many issues I want to discuss
with INA from women's rights and free
speech to Islamism and political
correctness,
but I also want to talk to her about
life in France right now.
Has it changed since the Paris terror
attacks?
What's the political climate?
Has the regressive mentality steeped
into the mainstream,
thus weakening free speech and helping
the authoritarians.
The only way we can find answers to
questions like these is to be connected
with people who aren't afraid to share
their views.
You know there's a catch 22 to all this
connectivity as it brings us closer and
transcends cultures and borders.
It can also make everyone else's
problems seemed like our own.
On one hand,
we can see how others live and have
empathy for our fellow men.
On the other hand,
sometimes it's hard to gauge just how
much something across the globe should
affect us in our day to day lives.
I try to do this show each week in the
spirit of finding balance between those
two concepts and I hope you know,
we'll provide perspective on some of the
big questions I've mentioned here.
The more we focus on our common
humanity,
the less chance we'll be able to be
ripped apart.
Initiative Chanko is the leader of the
International Women's movement,
Feminine,
a writer,
a speaker,
and a fearless free speech advocate.
You know,
welcome to the show.
Hello.
Hi.
Thank you for invitation for long I
should say.
Well,
I'm really glad that we connected.
I,
I've known about your work for awhile
and then I saw a piece that you wrote in
the International Business Times last
week about the regressive left and the
racist right.
And that basically most of us are in
between and that's very much what,
what we've been talking about here on
this show.
So I thought it would be a perfect time
to talk to you.
So you're,
you're in Austria right now,
is that right?
I'm right now in Australia.
What?
Can I ask what you're doing there?
Or is this a top secret mission?
Yeah,
no,
I'm,
I'm here for a conference about free
speech of course.
I hope that this time it will not be
interrupted by a terrorist.
We will be speaking and enjoy this
topic.
Discussing this topic.
Alright,
well we're going to talk about some of
the interruptions that you've had a by
terrorists when you're giving talks on
free speech.
But first let's do a little bit on your
biography because I think it's pretty
amazing.
I mentioned at the top of the show you
were born in Ukraine,
not the Ukraine.
You were born in Ukraine the same year
that the Soviet Union fell and I think
that had a lot to do with sort of your,
your path right now because of things
that you saw in a sort of newborn
country.
So can you talk a little bit about your
history first?
Well,
I was born the year my country was born
actually.
And um,
of course the situation,
you know,
for me as a child,
for me it was just,
just a childhood,
but for adults it was of course a rough
reality.
Then later I understood that I had a
rough childhood.
However,
you know,
for me to make a homework under the
candles because all our electricity in
the city was shot for the sake of the
economy.
You know,
we didn't have,
we didn't have a national currency.
And uh,
uh,
my parents were a receiving salary with
sausages or was breads,
you know.
And um,
yeah,
I mean,
poverty.
I'm powered to a spot that,
you know,
and uh,
I think that this is not something
special for yeah to,
to tell you about because still until
today,
many people live in poverty and 25 years
after Ukraine,
um,
well actually right now in a similar
situation and uh,
you know,
already my nephew,
a small child who is eight years old,
he near in this similar situation and
has similar childhood to what I had so
situation is that really changing and
progressing.
But of course it had a really a huge
impact on me.
And,
uh,
I think when the old generation that was
born after the collapse of the USSR,
because we saw what we saw that,
um,
you know,
as adults,
we're saying our country was ruled by
450 idiots.
This is,
I'm quoting particularly,
yeah,
my grandma and my mother,
they were calling them all adults.
We're calling politicians always,
you know,
there was always this clear gap between
society and those 450 Egypt's again,
as they say.
Um,
there was always a gambit between
government and citizens and,
um,
you could,
you as a child,
I never could imagine that it could be
any connection between those people,
between this small group of people that
we could call one percent and 99 percent
of the population.
There was all this an impression as if
we were living in different countries.
I saw,
of course,
you know,
I grew up in a very traditional society
where woman has to work and uh,
well to have job and also of course take
care of everything at home.
And even though my father was not a
particular patriarch,
but of course all the while my mother
was a housewife.
Um,
as well as I'm working full time and in
nineties,
um,
during,
well during this time of,
you know,
trying to create a government in the
country,
have to collapse a few ceasar parents
had to work on different jobs and uh,
my,
my mother was working on three different
jobs and of course taking care of us at
home,
which of course gave an impression,
um,
and kind of,
you know,
well yeah,
we had to paint a picture of what woman
is supposed to do and what her mission
is and what men is supposed to do.
And even in such a hard economically
time,
my father was of course earning much
more and had access to more jobs and
could,
could have possibility to find different
jobs.
More interesting than my mother.
Women really were doing two jobs because
they were working and they were taking
care of the home and the kids and all
that.
Yeah,
I don't,
I,
yeah,
I think it's incorrect to speak in the
past because as I already decided,
remains the realities still a exactly
the same.
And maybe sometimes we have an illusion,
you know,
expect in a different cover and we can
see more women who do not do that.
However,
still a majority of women live that
life.
And My mother's still continues to work
in two different jobs today.
And uh,
well she doesn't have children anymore.
We're going.
So I don't think you think there's
anything wrong with that in and of
itself.
You just sort of want people to
acknowledge the role of the woman,
right?
What do you mean?
I don't think
well that they're doing that they're
doing both these things that they,
it's not bad to take care of your kids
in and of itself,
right?
Oh,
too bad to take care of your kids.
But it's bad if you're the only one this
post to take care of your kid.
Right?
So the role,
the role.
Well,
yeah,
exactly that you have to follow the role
and you have no choice.
And uh,
um,
I think,
uh,
I think there's a lot of things that are
wrong in this,
in this concept and in this reality.
And therefore,
uh,
we are,
we started a movement in Ukraine as a
women's movement,
feminist movement,
even though at the beginning I should
confess when we started our activity,
we didn't really have a clear
understanding what feminism was about
because for example,
to give you,
um,
yeah,
to give you an example,
I was studying in the Best University of
Ukraine.
I was studying journalism and uh,
four years of my studies,
I never had it been even one hour
lecture on what feminism is.
Wow.
I didn't even hear the definition of
sanctuary ideology because that was
something which is not close to Eastern
European society again,
where women have to be at home and take
care of who have family but not go into
street and demand their rights.
Um,
actually it's not concerning only
women's rights,
but generally I grew up in the country
where people do not until 2008 and 2004,
sorry.
Uh,
the moment of orange revolution.
The first revolution that happened in
the history of independent Ukraine.
Until that moment people didn't have a,
you know,
to,
to protest was a,
you know,
an activity of a bad taste,
it was something that you wouldn't do.
It was something that you would do only
to,
I'm probably earn money because
political parties in Ukraine pay you for
I'm sending was the flags in the streets
and protesting supporting one or another
politician.
So when we started our activity we were
of course accused accused for being paid
by someone and being political project
or also being named by our parents or
relatives who knew that we don't get
money for that.
We were just simply named either witches
or psychologically sick girls.
Right.
Okay.
So I don't want to jump too far ahead
yet.
So we're going,
we're going to go into.
We're going to go into all that,
but just to sort of wrap up the Ukraine
part because I think a lot,
you know,
there's so much happening with Ukraine
and as you said,
it is a young country.
It's only 25 years old in terms of
independence.
What do you make of what's happening in
Ukraine now?
Because it,
it sort of seems like the quest for true
independence in a way has failed because
Russia is,
is back in Ukraine.
Right.
So is it,
do you feel like you're part that
Ukraine is really an independent state
at this point?
Well,
Ukraine is an independent state and I
think that nobody should it.
Um,
well,
of course putting questions in Russia is
questioning it.
Yeah.
But,
so Ukraine is an independent state,
of course,
even though our territory,
we're already taking an occupied like
Crimea,
um,
work presently occupied in Ukraine last
right now and still there is the eastern
part of Ukraine occupied by a Russian
military troops and I will say bravely,
uh,
I will claim that their Russian troops
as it was proven,
um,
well,
Ukraine is an independent state,
which is definitely at the stage of its
development and creation and,
you know,
choosing the path a while 99 percent of
population today,
a screaming,
oh,
for your integration and for wish to
join European Union or a dream because I
think it's quite a remote possibility
yet.
Um,
there is still,
um,
the garments,
the one that I mentioned about 450
agents remain.
They remain those people because,
well,
I should say that the problem of my
country,
what my country,
the country where I was born,
um,
because I don't feel like I have a
country.
Um,
I think that the problem of this country
is that a,
for 25 years at least I observed the
same faces in the parliament.
I hear the same names of politicians.
It's the country is ruled by the same.
If you want,
you know,
methia oligarch who,
unions fractions,
for example,
today's President Poroshenko,
who's,
you know,
supposed to be and he claims to be the
one who is for your integration.
Um,
he was a minister of foreign affairs in
the,
uh,
cabinets in a parliament of President
Yanukovych who was recently the dictator
against who people went out recently.
I'm at the square in my down and key up.
So definitely I,
I should say that this sort of
evolution,
you know,
I think that it's,
it's a,
uh,
intellectually unfair and wrong to think
that after people go out and destroy the
evolution is when people go out on the
street.
Well,
no,
it's beginning of it.
It's,
it's beginning of the protests and I
think that the protests started in 2004,
the first orange revolution 10 years
after people again went out in the
street because the changes didn't happen
today.
Again,
many people are deceived because don't
see rapid changes.
But,
uh,
I think that's a mistaken and wrong to
expect changes right away.
I think that's,
I think that Ukraine will have to.
We'll have to have few more revolutions.
Yeah.
So speaking of that,
do you,
do you think,
what does the average person in Ukraine
feel about how the rest of the world
views them now?
Because I sensed that the people of
Ukraine want more help from the west and
that,
you know,
in America we talk about it,
we talked about it for like the two
weeks that Putin was moving troops in or
whatever.
It was a,
there was a two week window where we
talk about it now.
It just,
we just completely forget about it.
Is there a disappointment on behalf of
the people,
sort of how the world has reacted to
what's happened there?
Well,
of course,
yes,
there is a disappointment because,
um,
you know,
people feel that people know that their
government is actually unable to do
something to change thing.
And since people give,
you know from this square and my,
there were giving the messages to the
world,
of course they do expect from other
states the more powerful or so called
democratic,
who already reached a certain level who
could help and support and especially
those who support it verbally,
but do not support support practically.
Uh,
of course,
many people are,
as I said,
deceived and disappointed today.
And even some come to the point when
they say that a younger core image was
the dictator,
it was better because at least what to
eat.
And he did,
his government didn't touch.
Yeah.
So,
so last thought on this and then we're
gonna move on to some of the feminism
stuff.
I mean,
wasn't,
am I correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think didn't Ukraine have nukes,
which they gave up as part of that they
would get NATO protection once they were
an independent nation and basically that
just didn't happen.
Right?
So they sort of gave up their protection
that the weapons that would have
protected them and then they get this
invasion or whatever you want to call it
from Russia and now the other countries
right there doing nothing.
We're doing nothing.
So it was,
it was really like,
uh,
an unfortunate decision I suppose.
Well,
uh,
I'm in,
if we will go right now in discussing
about a decision or NATO,
I think it will be too complex.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Or because,
uh,
well there are a lot of sides of this
question,
but yes,
this is what happened.
And,
uh,
of course,
many people today thinking back and
think that what kind of mistakes we're
done,
but at that moment it seemed to be very
correct to a decision because,
uh,
you know,
nobody could expect that Putin suddenly
I'm decides to occupy the territory is
proved the world that he's even bigger
dictator then into the world.
Perceive him.
Okay,
well,
I know we can talk about that political
stuff forever.
So let's,
let's move on to this stuff that you're
really passionate about.
And it's funny because at the top of the
show I do my direct message where I give
my feelings of the week and I wrote my
little piece about it yesterday.
And then right after I wrote it,
I watched your Ted talk and basically
your Ted talk was a 20 minute sort of
much broader version of exactly what I
happened to write about yesterday by,
by total coincidence.
And I know that the things that you talk
about are the things that I'm incredibly
passionate about and that I've made the
show that.
So you had a great quote in your,
in your Ted Talk,
you said that feminine is a movement
that is trying to rebuild society
without permission.
I love that line.
So can you just expand on that a little
bit and what,
what made you start feminine and where
do you think it's going?
Well,
particularly by that statement,
I should say that anyone who is dreaming
to rebuild the world should come.
That you know,
you should not ask for permission
because nobody will ever give it to you.
So if you dream to change something,
you should not ask for permission or
weight when someone will give you that
impression
waiting a long time.
Right?
And it will never happen.
Yes.
Because,
well,
in Ukraine as,
as I said,
we started in Ukraine a movement in
2008.
I'm aware existed movement already exist
for eight years and um,
I should say that's the one we started.
We didn't have any particular knowledge
of political knowledge or didn't know
how to work with media.
I told you already did that.
We didn't really have a clear,
uh,
understanding what feminism is about.
Um,
and,
um,
I don't feel embarrassed or shy to say
about that because I think that this
should show and reflect the society in
which we were growing up.
Um,
I remember joining this little group
about,
which nobody knew at that moment yet.
Um,
we were when we had the meeting in a
very Soviet style cafe in the center of
Kiev,
sharing two cups of tea,
a on 50 for 15 of us because we were all
young students coming from small cities
to keep dreaming that this will be the,
the,
the place where we will have is women
opportunities.
And the only opportunities we will
propose even in this big city in capital
that looked for us,
you know,
huge,
tremendous,
uh,
place.
Um,
we,
we only had the opportunity as well
similar to those that I saw,
um,
the opportunities that women had in my
childhood,
you know,
to serve someone.
And of course,
very often Ukrainian women are,
uh,
because,
mainly claim that they are beautiful.
But what is true,
they're not educated and poor.
And this becomes a reason to involve,
usually involve women in sexual
exploitation,
prostitution.
And of course,
um,
you know,
on my way to university everyday,
all right,
I could be here,
first of all,
harassed second,
received many flyers,
uh,
from,
what pimps or brothers who would propose
you to go to work and many women,
many girls did a goal and you know,
applied for such a job because you don't
have other disabilities because you're
not horrible than anything else.
So for us to first reason to start the
activity was to fight this disease,
this illness of Eastern Europe.
Oh,
considering women as sex slaves,
this prostitute.
And we were campaigning against
prostitution and sex tourism,
which is a really widespread disease in
Ukraine particularly.
Um,
and we were competing against that
wearing pink clothes and carrying pink
balloons and pink flags,
believing that was this pink color.
We will attract attention to,
um,
to this problem.
However,
of course we failed and,
uh,
organizing protests with hundred,
200 female activists and nobody was even
stopping when they were passing by to
read our banners.
And,
uh,
we were in search of tactics of the
waste,
how we can attract attention of this
very political.
Um,
again,
desperate society to something very
essential to the rights of women,
something that the whole world is
already talking about,
accepting,
changing,
you know,
adopting laws.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
well,
for two years we,
uh,
we,
we were in desperate search and uh,
um,
in 2010 we saw that the situation in
Ukraine was changing because I'm the
dictator,
which we understood later,
dictator Yanukovych was elected as a
president and distribution was changed.
You could immediately feel the sends
ship in media could immediately feel the
change of political situation and the
more than the country.
And we understood that,
uh,
we'll probably have to go as a female
activist as a female.
Voices would probably have to complain
about something broader or something
that brings us to this problem,
you know,
more limited problems such as
prostitution and sex tourism.
Um,
something that is to the root of the
problem,
the political situation,
the economical situation,
those people who bring the society,
uh,
in such state.
So we did our first topless projects,
2010,
to be honest.
Uh,
it was more,
as an experiment.
It was also sort of a scream from inside
and as I said it was,
it was a decision made during this,
you know,
being in a very,
in a desperate search of how to let
people hear women's voices and their
problems.
How did that first moment feel for you
when you did the topless protest?
Because you guys,
even if it hadn't picked up much
traction,
you were already talking about things as
you've said that we're sort of not
accepted in society.
So you're already going against the
grain,
but then,
yeah,
you realized,
all right,
we've got to do something that's going
to really get us publicity the right way
and all that.
How did literally that first moment when
you took off your top feel?
Well,
I should say that I didn't do that that
moment because I did it a year after
because we had a huge discussion in the,
in the group,
um,
well,
sort of in the fights about whether to
do it or not.
Uh,
uh,
because so,
and I was one of those who were against
topless protests,
so that came later for me.
But I'm definitely had a huge effect
because we have now,
we not only had the unpopular speech,
but we also use them very unpopular
tactic.
We were showing something,
any job,
a woman,
which is very important to learn this
society.
The image of a woman which was popular
in Ukraine was the,
you know,
a nice,
smiling,
sexy,
a cleaning lady.
Um,
but so we were showing a screaming and
grape bare breasted woman.
What was the message was slogan written
across her chest,
uh,
which was something that was breaking
completely the definition,
you know,
the,
yeah,
the definition or imagination that the
contexts in which people could see that
the woman and the definition of woman in
generally in Ukraine.
And uh,
of course it was a,
it attracted a lot of attention or
different attention as well as some
support.
There is support from Ukraine.
And of course,
uh,
we felt a huge support from abroad.
Um,
and a lot of criticism,
of course,
of course we would have been named a
prostitutes immediately because we were
naked,
which again revealed something that,
um,
for people,
you know,
naked woman is equal to prostitutes.
And I'm actually,
I should say that it was this topless
project,
what we are reaching,
I think that we're committing sort of a
test for democracy.
We commit a test,
we test the society and uh,
uh,
with this tactic was the messages and
speeches that we have with test society
and will reveal a lot.
Um,
we reveal a lot on the reaction on those
projects.
So I should say that what we actually do
very often people say feminine are
violent because we are aggressive
because we're screaming.
I'm so,
which immediately makes the fear that
for people,
you know,
a woman who is angry is the violence is
something violent.
We,
you'll find to see angry men,
but with women,
which is not smiling or keeping silent,
but who's screaming is something
violent.
Really,
a we probably killed were probably
feeling some people buy our messages.
Um,
I mean,
of course literally we do not harm.
We do not,
we do not interact,
you know,
we don't touch anyone physically.
We can touch and attack ideas.
We buy our ideas,
but what actually do is we appear take
off our top and strip.
Our ID is written and our buddies we
create.
I think that we transform our bodies in
the political messages,
in our manifesto,
in posters if you want this.
These are posters on which we write our
slogans.
And uh,
I think this way we,
I think it's kind of,
yeah,
there are a few functions because the
first function of course is to provoke,
to attract attention.
Second is that we change the meaning of
what naked budget it is.
It's not.
There are so many.
You can see women,
naked women everywhere on covers of
magazines,
on billboards.
They opposing smiling,
sexy.
What we're showing,
we're showing woman who's not sexy,
but uh,
you know,
she's political her by this political.
She's not smiling,
she's screaming,
she's not inviting you to use her.
She's refusing.
She is showing her anger.
She's showing that she's demanding
something.
And of course this is something that
breaks a lot of stereotypes and rules.
And traditions in particularly in
society like Ukraine have generally in
many countries,
we received a very different reaction of
such protests and I think it reveals a
lot.
It mirrors a lot.
Well,
what's interesting is you're really
talking about the true roots of what
feminism really is.
You are demanding to be accepted as an
absolute equal to a man,
which really is what you first wave
feminism here in the west was.
It's now changed and morphed into
something else.
But all you're demanding sort of is
equality.
Um,
I've seen you described as a sex
streaming.
Do you like that word?
Do you guys,
you've used that word a little bit,
but I've heard it about you more.
Alright.
Well this is the word that we created
actually,
and we're done.
It defines itself is sex drummist.
Um,
because we use our sex,
the fact that we have female as our
weapons.
Our God is our weapons.
And I think this is also sort of a not
unser to fundamentalist terrorists who
use the gun,
who actually killed people.
We showed them our,
my buddies,
my weapon.
Because first of all,
you are scared of it as if it was
actually a weapon who,
which could kill you in a second.
We see that this budget really can
destroy,
um,
you know,
can destroy bad ideas or at least
challenge them or provoke them a great
discussion.
So yes,
we call it ourselves is because we use
our sex,
sex as a weapon,
our bodies,
our weapon.
Okay.
So as I mentioned at the top of the
show,
and as you've illustrated here,
quite obviously,
it's not just that you talk about these
things,
but you literally are putting your life
on the line.
I mean,
just by taking your shirt off,
the amount of people who you've angered,
it's,
it's incredible.
It's crazy.
But you've also had very close brushes
with the law,
with actual terrorism and violence.
Can you go into a couple examples of the
KGB example in boundaries and just,
and,
and you were literally an event that you
were speaking about,
free speech was shot up.
Uh,
and there's some crazy audio of that.
Can you just talk about those two
examples?
Well,
yes,
I think,
I think this is what I was talking about
that will reveal a lot of things with
this protest,
but to be honest,
we didn't expect that we will,
you know,
just topless woman was the worst written
across the chest,
could um,
you know,
could invite the garments and secret
services to chase them,
arrest them,
kidnapped them and torture.
We have been literally tortured in
bellerose after one of our projects that
we staged in December 2011,
which was an anniversary 19 December
2011 anniversary of a one year
anniversary for huge German stroke
patient in the co where during which
many people have been arrested,
mainly disappeared and some reportedly
have been killed.
But the information is always hidden
there.
And we stayed in ironical protest,
mocking a dictator.
Luca Shen come in front of a KGB office,
which is officially official kg be,
um,
a service there.
And during the protests,
journalists have been grabbed by the
staff,
a kgb stuff.
The man who came out of the office of
KGB and we,
we were ignored so we could leave the
place.
They certainly knew that they will be
able to catch us before the,
what was important,
but in that moment for them to stop the
journalist from releasing the images.
Um,
however,
some journalists managed to do it.
They left before I'm having an
experience,
obviously working in Belarus and later,
a few hours after when we were at the
bus station in Maine,
Cisco on our way back to Kiev to
Ukraine,
um,
we have been grabbed and thrown into bus
in which we spend the whole night of
being questioned by men.
Um,
well,
we saw their faces.
They didn't hide themselves,
but,
uh,
they were clearly saying that they're
kgb and they were asking us who paid us
for this protests.
They were saying that,
uh,
would they know that Europe pays us,
which is ridiculous,
you know,
who is Europe?
I was trying to ask them as well.
They did sir.
Um,
because they were the ones asking
questions.
So,
um,
yeah.
And uh,
after that night we have been brought to
a forest,
uh,
in which we changed the buses.
We were taking the bus and there was
another group of men,
a faces of who we couldn't see anymore,
uh,
because,
um,
the plastic handcuffs and our hands and
we were not allowed to move and had to
keep our heads down and looking on the
floor.
Um,
well we heard during I think five,
six hours drive,
we heard that we will be killed.
We heard the description,
you know,
different description of how we can be
killed at and uh,
um,
we will ask to,
to breathe loud because they wanted to
hear us breathing saying that in few
hours we will not be able to breathe.
They were saying that they will send our
core parts of bodies to our mothers and
so on and so forth,
which was of course done very
professionally.
Um,
you know,
you could feel that this man do this
everyday.
It's their job actually to retort to
people like that.
Um,
we received a few hits,
but they were not beating us severely,
but later we were taking out of the bus
in a forest and they're,
um,
what they were.
They were doing a horrible things such
as putting the blame on us and playing
very,
you know,
coming with a fire very close to the
body.
So you feel like you would,
they will burn you alive right now.
They made us undress a turn and so they
were creating situations when you feel
like next second they will rape you,
they will burn you,
they will kill you,
they will cut you a,
you know what they did,
they cut my hair was knife,
they were,
you know,
they throw some uh,
know green antiseptic and my face,
which I couldn't wash away or like
things that were somehow at some point
with some,
it's ridiculous,
but it was,
it was tortured,
was psychological and physical torture.
They were filming everything on to video
cameras.
So it was supposed to be reported to
someone,
uh,
and uh,
we,
so 15 men around us and masks and the
fact that they were wearing masks made
me think that they will not kill us
because they hide their faces.
Um,
however,
I didn't know how far they will go in
their action and uh,
they after this torture,
they throw us out of the forest and,
uh,
we spent another five hours,
six hours to find someone and we found a
village,
what village?
It's a big word probably for seven
houses,
and we were in the middle of the forest.
We found them.
We were lucky enough that at that moment
there was someone who came from the CT
and had mobile phone and of course for
24 hours already all at least Russian
speaking world researching for us and
information was spread everywhere and we
easily contacted our colleagues and
journalists.
And later four hours later,
the embassy of Ukraine arrived to police
station,
which we were staying for some time.
And it took us back to Kiev.
Um,
well this is one of the experience,
uh,
um,
you know,
in Ukraine,
um,
also we constantly were falling over by
secret services,
threatened and uh,
um,
well they opened for criminal cases
against us for hooliganism.
This is some thing that they use in
Ukrainian Russia against political
activist.
For example,
right now the reserve artists pop
landscape who burned the door of a
Russian secret service,
um,
and he's also redundancy hooligan.
Well,
they treat us as a whole against,
because this is something very vague,
you know,
you could,
um,
you could pull anyone who like and,
and uh,
yeah.
And then Ukraine,
uh,
after our first and very loud protest
against union of Church and state,
um,
I had to flee.
I had to leave the country because,
uh,
well,
literally I had to jump out from the
window of my apartment a jump in the car
and run away.
Um,
when this stuff has happened to you,
I mean,
I know you can,
you have so many examples of this which
we could,
you know,
we could spend hours talking about,
but when these things have happened to
you,
I mean,
what happened to you in that forest?
It sounds horrific.
You survive,
but obviously their goal is
intimidation.
Their goal of course,
is to silence you.
And then by silencing you they silence
your followers and that's how they end
you guys.
They don't have to actually kill you.
So I'm curious afterwards,
after something like that happens,
do you or did you feel all right,
maybe we've taken this as far as it
should go or did it,
did you immediately double down and say,
now we're getting somewhere with this?
Well,
of course I'm not going to play a
superhero.
And of course you have older fear you
feel you'll feel that I will not right
after you.
I will never do it again.
Um,
but then,
you know,
after some time thinking about it and
really spending time on repeating in
your mind what really happened?
You understand that it's not,
it's not us who went too far is their
reaction goes too far,
probably because we do something which
they don't want to happen.
And so it means that we do something
very right.
And I think,
of course,
again,
I will never deny that we have fear.
We do have fear,
but I should say that the fear of the
fear of giving up to those people is
much bigger than fear of being taken to
the forest.
At least you already know how it feels
and what it is.
Um,
and again,
your fear,
it's a choice,
right?
So we'll probably make a choice not to
fear but to who to deal with the fear
and to continue the activity because
again,
just think about how ridiculous actually
this all is.
There are girls who take off their tops
and write slogans and for that had taken
to the forest,
KGB staff,
I spending with them 24 hours torturing
them and doing all the insane things.
How ridiculous this is.
How ridiculous is the fact that there
are people blending terrorists,
attacks,
taking guns,
blowing themselves up because they want
to stop those who drove her car
but caricatures do,
you know who drove very funny or not
funny for some cartoons,
but something so peaceful.
So somehow very childish as well.
You know,
it was something very simple.
So I think that it also reveals a lot of
shows,
um,
how it shows the.
Yeah,
how crippled our society is,
how the,
how we,
we replaced the fight or the.
Yeah,
the fights a of ideas by actually divide
between people.
And uh,
I think that this is the reason to
continue.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
sometimes people say,
well,
you're ready to do it for six years and
you're only 25 and you already have been
nearly killed at least three times.
What,
what makes you go on?
But this actually,
this is exactly the reason that make you
go go on because you understand that
just because you say,
you know,
you write three words in your body or
you write an article or you draw a
cartoon,
they went to kill you for that.
Isn't it ridiculous?
Doesn't make sure that I leave in six
society and because I don't want to live
in society,
I continue,
I go on,
I know that the history of my time is
written right now and,
uh,
well to let fundamentalist,
a dictator's misogynists to write
history of my time.
Well,
I don't agree with that.
I want to participate writing the
history.
Yeah,
I mean,
listen,
I love everything you just said though.
The whole spirit of everything that I do
is exactly that.
You're at,
you're at the front lines of it.
So that's a good segue actually to,
in 2013,
uh,
you got asylum in France and you live in
France now,
and that must've been an interesting
time to move to France because shortly
after that a was the Charlie Hebdo
attacks.
Now you,
you knew some of the cartoonists,
right?
You had worked with them a little bit.
Um,
so can you talk about that?
Well,
I knew all the Darnest,
um,
those who died and those who survived as
well.
Um,
we had to,
well,
we were friends,
we were really friends and we spend a
lot of time just together debating,
discussing and sharing what was shared.
A lot of ideas and to be honest,
when I arrived to France and after few
of protest that we organized in France
and clearly stated our direct message,
not message,
which is following all these demands of
political correctness.
No unnecessary political,
correct.
It is.
And you rope.
I'm Charlotte.
We're the only one who were really on
the same line with us and we became
really friendly and it's very,
very soon.
And we even made a,
a,
one issue of Charlotte though together
with feminine.
Um,
and uh,
well yeah,
and of course we will sometime we were
spending ridging to each other,
the threats that we were receiving and
laughing and making fun of the,
of the fanatics who were spending time
for writing those threats and uh,
you know,
writing this pitches which they were a
recording
now.
Voicemails.
Um,
yeah,
and of course losing your friends,
not only friends,
you know.
Yeah,
not only friends,
but I do a logic ideological friends or
brothers if you want was of course was
again something which of course it's
personally very hard and have a,
a lose,
but also is something that reveals the
Lord,
shows you again,
shows you that if you stop,
then you will fail and new ideas will
fail.
I believe that maybe it will be,
it will sound a bit old,
but even those cartoonists who died,
who were killed,
they didn't lose and their ideas,
they are not,
the ideas are not failure.
They,
they will always remain as a nurse and
it,
those who continue to do what they
believed in and that what they believe
in is the right thing because they will
not harm anyone.
They were contributing to a very
important,
since things such as freedom of
expression and they were contributing to
this to keep and save the values of
France as well,
which is a liberty equality fraternity,
which is,
you know,
sometimes today you think that it,
it,
it remains only on the buildings written
on the buildings,
but not actually in life,
not actually applied and life of society
anymore.
So Charlotte Heroes,
part of being friends,
they are heroes.
Uh,
however,
I should also mention that just the
months before they,
they were killed,
they were racist,
Islamophobes,
uh,
you know,
they,
they will always named for being too
much for going too far,
for,
for offending.
We all know that.
Right?
And just to be very clear,
I know this has been said a thousand
times over,
but they were not racist and they were
not Islamophobia,
which is a made up word by the way,
but they were not.
They were pointing out the,
they made fun of everybody and I think
something like it's three percent of the
covers were about Islam,
but they equally attacked Christianity
and Judaism and all the religions.
It was about power.
So they were making cartoons about the
exact things that you were protesting in
the streets.
It was really kind of amazing.
I mean,
I think what you mentioned just now that
only three percent of the covers and
they're all material in newspaper was
about Islam also shows something that we
were also discussing with them often and
you know,
as we talk about France and things that
happened in France,
maybe to make sense to quote a voluntary
gain here.
Um,
and this words attribute it to him.
He said that if you want to find out who
rules over you,
simply understand who you are not
allowed to criticize.
So even this three percent,
you know,
of the,
of the information or the,
the,
the topic,
you know,
I slept,
it was just taking three percent of the,
of the whole information off Charlotte
door really shows a lot.
So that of course is the youngest from
three minutes they stick religions,
the most ambitious probably today,
the most demanding religion.
It really reveals its face to face and
reacts in a different way.
Right.
So I know you've talked about the
regressive left and it started for me,
Charlie Hebdo was the beginning of my
awakening which happened over the course
of the next year or so.
Um,
but what do you make of the group of
people and we had plenty of them here in
the United States and I'm sure you had
plenty of them in France as well.
People on the left,
people that are for women's rights and
for gay rights and for minority rights
that suddenly when it came to what
happened with Charlie Hebdo at,
ah,
you shouldn't have,
you know,
you shouldn't have made fun of the
cartoons.
You shouldn't have done these cartoons.
Talked about the profit,
whatever it is,
people who otherwise are totally for
free speech and free expression.
Suddenly they're not in this case.
Uh,
so what do you make of those people and
how pervasive is that idea in France
these days?
Well,
um,
you said that it all started for you off
to Charlotte.
Do I think that it became so visible in
France as well after Charlotte recently
also after Cologne attacks in Germany,
uh,
which we can also discuss not only
lectures but also feminist reaction or
feminist non-reaction.
Uh,
so I think that's a,
yeah,
it's after these events we could see
this,
you know,
fraction of leftists who would deny the
ins the essential problem,
who would be scared to talk about the
roots of the problem,
who will,
who will be willing not to talk about
Charlotte killers as people with guns
and not discuss their ideas and not
discuss what they were screaming wild
shooting our friends,
what they were in,
in the name of who they committed these
atrocities and what made them could
believe.
And then they have to do that.
So,
um,
I think that this is something,
again,
which of course brings Europe in a very
big danger and especially the values of
Europe in a very big danger.
And therefore,
I say that sometimes working in Paris,
I read this three words that the slogan
of French Revolution,
and I understand that this is very far
from reality today from the society,
and of course you hear the leaders,
the leftest leaders here who tried to,
you know,
make speeches to defend freedom of
expression and make of Charlotte door a
heroes,
um,
because they're,
you know,
John List who fell down but they do not,
will not want to discuss for which ideas
they,
they found that for which ideas they
were killed.
So many of them,
you know,
of course do it.
I'm out of fear,
but very different theater.
There is a very big fear to be a,
to have similar speech too,
right wing,
similar speech to actually xenophobes
and racists such as Japan here in
France,
therefore left is decided to take this
very ridiculous,
again,
intellectually dishonest position such
as denying their roots.
And they did the real,
the,
the central problem in the situation.
And I think this way,
the betrayal.
So the ideas of Charlotte and of course,
yes.
So at the end,
the result is that it's only or extreme
right wing,
the racists,
the xenophobes who are speaking out
actually.
Yeah.
And this is,
this is what I've said repeatedly here,
is that we on the left have to deal with
this because if we don't,
and this is exactly what your peace in
the international business times was
about.
If,
if the,
if we don't deal with the regressive
left,
then who do we hand it to?
The racist,
right?
That,
that was your,
your term.
And I couldn't agree more.
So when you say that France in terms of
free speech and uh,
people getting along,
would you say Francis in a worse
position now,
do you think that there was a net loss
in free speech after Charlie Hebdo?
Because there were a couple weeks after
where the whole world united and,
and you know,
all those world leaders came to Paris
and it sounded like something good was
going to happen.
But I sent you think it's probably the
reverse now.
Well,
again,
there are so many aspects to discuss
here.
This manifestation that happened after
the 11th of January was ridiculous.
And,
uh,
the,
the cartoonists who survived a lose,
for example,
who made the next cover,
uh,
was Muhammad was prophet,
I'm crying,
we were laughing with him again.
Parity.
It's true.
Rebel,
laughing because in front of him there
was a line of all the enemies of ideas
of Charlotte and they will marching,
you know,
again,
if this event was so full of hypocrisy
because fact they were marching at least
this front line.
Well,
marching,
not for the,
not for the right ideas,
you know,
they were pretending they were.
Yeah,
it was,
it was fake.
I'm not talking about the million of
people,
but I'm talking about this front line,
which was totally ridiculous.
And what happened after there was so
many events dedicated to discussion of
free speech,
which we were,
which were cancelled by the government,
by police,
uh,
in order to,
you know,
for,
for security reasons or events in which
me,
myself was supposed to participate.
So many of them were canceled.
Again,
the event that happened just one month,
often Copenhagen during which I was
speaking,
was interrupted by another terrorist.
And,
uh,
again,
one person who had been killed and
injured.
So this way,
you know,
again,
I think that we failed after Charlotte,
do we failed with all this ridiculous
thing such as inviting,
actually the,
the representatives or those of those
who are feeding the terrorist,
um,
those who feed the ideas that are well
actually cannot go exist with ideas of
freedom of speech.
Inviting them to Paris to March for
ideas of Charlotte is something that
already showed that we will fail in this
discussion.
And I don't want to make your conclusion
that we did fail,
but I feel we are failing.
I'm here in Europe.
The Europe is fading.
European society is failing because
they're not ready to weld to face.
Very uncomfortable,
very unpleasant,
but truth,
they are not,
they are not able to hear.
Unpopular speech and freedom of speech
is really about something.
If liberty is really something,
it's definitely about unpopular speech.
It's about hearing,
accepting this unpopular,
uncomfortable speech and to Europe is
failing of doing that.
So we only have a couple of minutes left
and I know we're just getting into the
meat of this,
so we're going to have to do this again
where we can talk for much longer,
but uh,
I,
I hear you on the Europe part and
that's,
I get so much email now from the same
people saying the same things in Denmark
and in France and in Germany and
Finland,
all of these countries,
people are saying the exact same things
that you're talking about and they feel
that there is no faith in the government
that the governments are going to do the
right things and all of that.
So,
uh,
so let's end on this.
So the Cologne event that,
that happened in Germany with this,
it sounds like a thousand men were
running rampant throughout the city and
it's unclear if they were all immigrants
or migrants or whatever it was.
The reaction to that must have been
particularly upsetting to you because he
dealt with sort of the free speech stuff
and bringing all these people in.
But it also directly.
This was in a direct assault on women.
So it really went to everything that you
care about was the reaction to that
because I saw a feminists that were not
defending the women.
I suddenly saw a feminist online,
well known feminists that were saying,
oh,
this is just an excuse for the
xenophobes and white men do it too.
And all of those things.
Uh,
so that was one must have been
particularly upsetting,
right?
Well,
it was,
um,
yeah,
of course it was not only on,
not only upsetting,
you don't.
I think that's,
yeah.
Today we use,
you look around and you see the,
those who were supposed to be your
allies,
those supports to share with you with a
very fundamental values.
And Stanford them either keep silence or
try to support.
Actually you are aggressors.
The of women,
just because of the fact it was reported
that among the aggressors were men know
who looked like Arabic man or north
African region feminists,
silence.
They didn't want to discuss,
uh,
what actually happened just because of
fear of again being,
you know,
having the speech of extreme right wing
and at the end who appeared to be actual
defenders of a women,
you know,
who were raped an aggressive after
prolonged what extreme,
right.
Wait again,
the platform was giving to them.
So I think that to those people who
write you emails and to people who write
me as well a lot and put support who
feel very feel betrayed,
the sad,
uh,
by the situation with that is going on
today in Europe by leftist reactions,
by the reaction,
some of a reaction of the feminists.
I think we have to understand that to be
sad is not enough to be sad,
you know,
makes people cry and a stay at home and
feel low,
you know,
alone.
But what we have to be,
many people don't like to face it,
but what we have to be today,
we have to be angry.
I think anger brings people to action.
Not Hate,
but anger.
Anger for defense,
for the fact that you ideas are
attacked,
that something very essential for your
life and joy of life which people have
today here.
Opportunity to enjoy life today,
here in Europe,
you have to defend it and for that you
have to feel anger.
Don't feel sad.
I feel angry.
Act and defend your ideas and don't let
the extreme right wing ride your own
history.
Let's write it with our own beautiful
liberal ideas.
That's my message.
Well,
you know,
I don't even have to ask you a final
question because you couldn't have ended
this any better.
You absolutely have an ally in me and
I'm sure and much of my audience so
everyone can find more of his
work@InaDashShevchenko.com.
I thank you for joining me and we
absolutely will do this again because I
feel like we just,
we just touched the surface of all this,
so thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.